Let's look at the solution to our
message passing versus shared memory
quiz.If we have one core
initializing an array, and
then all others reading
the entire array.
Data distribution, the number of
lines of code you need to do it
in message passing, is significant.
The number of lines of code we need for
that in shared memory is
really zero lines of code
because once the array is initialized
in memory others can simply read it.
They don't need to really
distribute the data in any way.
In contrast, in message passing
the core that initializes the array
now needs to send it explicitly
to all the other cores and
the other cores need to
receive it explicitly.
So there is definitely more
lines of code in message passing
than in shared memory.
Once you have the data distribution for
shared memory you don't
need do anything for it.
For message passing you need to send and
receive.
Synchronization that makes sure the
array is initialized before we get to
read it, adds how many lines of code?
In message passing, it adds 0 lines
of code because the sends and
receives that we needed to to do to
the receive the data already insure
that until we receive the array,
we cannot read it.
So when we get to read it after the
receive, we know that it's been already
initialized, because the send
happens after the initialization.
In shared memory, however,
while the initialization is happening,
the other threads could
just begin reading it, so
we need to add some explicit
synchronization out to make sure that
the reader's wait while
the initialization is happening.
So we here have more
than 0 lines of code.
In this case the message
passing code is simpler
as far as synchronization is concerned
than the shared memory code.
This is typically going to be what
happens between shared memory and
message passing.
Message passing needs to
distribute data, but in doing so
it also synchronizes.
Shared memory doesn't need to distribute
data, but if synchronization is needed
after the distribution it needs
to add explicit code to do that.